you and Ashton both big stars in the
business would you allow your child to
be in this business no I mean to say
that I wouldn't allow it would be
horrible but I really really like for
her to not be in the industry in any
form I think that if it was up to him
she would be the very first female
professional NFL coach specifically for
the Chicago Bears oh that's nice so that
is what he is molding her to be yeah how
is he doing that by forcing her to watch
football
every Sunday Monday night and Thursday
night and no I'm not kidding everybody
really this child has worn a Chicago
Bears onesy every Sunday for life every
Monday night of her life every Thursday
night of her life and never twice like
there are different onesies there with
two twos one is a like a cheerleader one
one's a jersey one has her name one
doesn't have her name maybe they are in
every everything so this is intense
it'll either either make her love all
that stuff or despise it go away no no
no no that's not gonna happen in this
house you will love football yeah well
me I just did you love football no I
will never watch football ever never
once until we started dating
really oh you didn't watch it football
till you met about it
truly knew nothing and now I know way
more than I ever intended to know or
anyone should know I really don't care
about football that's the truth but I
play along and I go yeah this is great
let's just all watch football but
through osmosis you're like oh my God
look at that that running back and
you're like you find yourself so you now
have all this information you didn't
even know that you had know where do I
want to have like does a part of my
brain that now will no longer be
intelligent
[Laughter]
[Applause]
your thumb good for you
you